one of our Kelly's former live-in
girlfriends is revealing what it was
like to spend nearly a decade with him
the docu-series surviving our Kelly
shows Dominique Gardner's mother
tracking her down after not having seen
her for years
they made a dramatic getaway now less
than a year after gardener left Kelly
for the last time she tells a New Yorker
the singer tried to in her words break
her she says kill it Kelly was
physically and emotionally abusive
Jericka Duncan is in Chicago where she
spoke to the author of the article
drinka good morning good morning
Dominique Gardner is now 27 years old
she says that she spent nine years
dating the R&B singer she told the
journalist Jim Deaver godess that even
though she loved our Kelly despite the
abuse she said she got two tattoos of
Kelly's face tattooed on her body she
was reluctant to speak out jim de
Regatas has been reporting on r kelly
for nearly two decades
last week he sat down with Dominique
Gardner for her first interview since
she left Kelly around nine months ago
she said to me I loved him and he loved
me and when it was good Jim it was
perfect and yet he hit me and yeah he
pulled out chunks of my hair and yeah he
beat me with an electrical cord but I
loved him and he loved me
Gardner told de Regatas at one point she
lived with Kelly and five other women
she said quote everything you do you
have to ask Kelly including when you can
eat or go to the bathroom she said she
often disobeyed and then suffered what
she called quote consequences including
spankings slapping and beatings she
seemingly is angry when describing some
of what she says she experienced but yet
and still she says he doesn't deserve
jail and he's really not a bad person he
needs help
I think neke is a really conflicted
young woman there's love and then
there's also fear there's anger and
there's pain last week we spoke to
Dominic's mother Michelle Kramer I can't
understand somebody say they love you
and then the same for
spinning your my face that's what you
say our Kelly did to your daughter yes
does Dominique believe she was
brainwashed no she rejects the word
brainwash she rejects the word cult she
told me what he tried to do is break me
break me and I wouldn't be broken
Gardner says that she decided to speak
out because she quote wanted to speak
her truth now yesterday Chicago police
were called to Kelly's residence because
of an anonymous tip about a suicide pact
police say a possible suicide pact
rather police say that report was
unfounded Kelly continues to deny all
accusations of abuse he is due back here
in family court later this morning
Gail tarika thank you